en este problema nos piden encontrar el
área de la región sombreada es decir
esta región que está en rojo observemos
que aquí afuera tenemos un cuadrado del
lado 10 y que cada una de estas regiones
blancas es un cuarto de circunferencia
de radio 3 me parece que podemos asumir
que todo esto vale 3 que la distancia de
este punto a cualquiera de estos es
igual a 3 entonces cada una de estas son
cuartos de circunferencia porque el
ángulo que tienen aquí es de 90 grados y
por lo tanto los cuatro cuartos hacen
una circunferencia entera de esta forma
una forma de encontrar el área de la
región sombreada es tomar el área total
que es 100 es el área del cuadrado 10
por 10 y a eso tenemos que restar el
área de una circunferencia de radio 3
esa área es y por 3 al cuadrado o sea 9
entonces para calcular el área de la
región sombreada a 100 le tenemos que
restar 9
vamos a comprobar la respuesta muy bien